Speaker 1: Why don't we try next. Oh, I don't
know. How about Lillith from Arizona. Lillith
from Arizona. You're on the air.
Speaker 4: And say hello. So I was
really questioning because you bring up quite
often about nasty programing and questioning.
Speaker 2: All right, I'm nervous. Never done this
Speaker 1: before. You're doing great. But it does
sound like you're half the time covering your
phone with something. So make sure everything's
uncovered. We want to hear you.
Speaker 4: Gotcha.
All right. Well, if you're saying that we
need like like some sort of nasty programing.
Yes. Right. Yeah, I'm trying to figure out,
like, how would we go about that? I don't know.
There's all this, like, anti intellectual
ism. Right. I think we really need, like,
an intellectual revolution or safe.
Speaker 1: OK, and what would
that look like, who would lead it?
Speaker 4: Wouldn't lead it. You know,
that's a that's a damn good question.
Speaker 1: Did you have any ideas at
all of who would lead it or.
Speaker 4: I think it would
have to be our use probably.
Speaker 1: OK, so youth would do
what in order to help Masti program?
Speaker 4: You know, that's that's
what I was that's what I was calling into
question, because I don't have the answers.
Speaker 1: Yeah, no, I don't either. I mean, you
have the kernel of a great idea. And I think the
youth are the future in a literal sense and a
proverbial sense. So I think young people should
be involved in it. But I just don't have the
answer. And we talked recently with Andy Norman
a little bit about Masti programing. And it is a
tough thing. It is a very I don't have any answers
and I don't know that we will anytime soon.
Speaker 4: And something else I was thinking
of is maybe like, you know, a revolution
of empathy. Yes, I think that's something
that would be needed, you know, for people to
understand each other and really try and approach
each other in like an empathetic way instead of
like, you know, going, like head to head so much.
Speaker 1: Well, there's a partizan
lack of empathy. In other words,
there is less empathy on the right in the brains
of people on the right. We know that. And that is
that that alone. But how do you how do you how do
you convince people to care about others? Right.
It's a really tough thing. It has a lot to do
with upbringing and and predisposition and so many
things. These are big, complicated issues, right?
Speaker 4: Yeah, yeah. Yeah. I don't know.
It's it's too much, honestly. Yeah. I wonder.
Speaker 1: All right. Well, thank you for the
call. I appreciate it.
Speaker 2: Yes, I
Speaker 1: know you're doing great.
Thank you. Great call. Great call.
Great first call to a program. I'm
sure the next one will be even better